[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sallyys
Welt heute möchte ich euch über die
kuchenmesse in Wels erzählen die vor ein
paar Wochen stattgefunden hat und am
Ende des Videos verkünde ich natürlich
heute auch die Gewinner der Schulranzen
und der selbstgebastelten schulldtüten
für mich war es der dritte Besuch in
Österreich das erste Mal da war ich in
der ZW klasse da war ich auf dem
Sportcamp okay das zählt nicht so ganz
es war nur ein paar Tage und dann das
zweite mal war auf der Messe in Wien vor
zwei Jahren da war ich hochschwanger und
das dritte Mal jetzt auf der Messe in
Wels und ich muss sagen ich bin durchaus
immer noch ja total mit positiv gestimmt
auf Österreich also es macht uns auch
unglaublich viel Spaß jedes Mal wieder
dor hin zureisen und wie jedes Mal ist
es bei be unseren Messen immer so dass
wir unsere LKWs selbst beladen und dann
natürlich auch den kompletten Messestand
von A bis Z selber aufbauen hat
natürlich den Vorteil dass wir immer
genau wissen was wohin muss und wir von
A bis Z einfach involviert sind und
einfach alle Bescheid wissen Nachteil
ist wir sind natürlich schon nach dem
ersten Tag ziemlich fertig aber das
Abendessen am Abend macht das Ganze dann
immer wieder gut gelmurat wir haben 40 2
40 Tonner sind zwei Riesen LKWs plus
noch ein kleinen Tonner kleinen Tonner
kleinen LKW und über 900 qu messest das
war schon der Hammer also als ich das
gehört habe habe ich schon gedacht wow
groß als ich es gesehen habe habe ich
gedacht okay mega groß dies haben wir
noch mal drauf gesetzt letzten Jahr
nächstes Jahr keine Ahnung noch ganz
eigene Messe genau D lass Pferde
rumlaufen Clowns Elefanten und allen
Drum dranau ja jedenfalls hatten wir
aber auch den Messestand und den ganzen
Platz gebraucht denn es waren auch
wirklich sehr viele Besucher da und ich
denke ich kann jetzt schon mal vorweg
sagen dass wirklich jeder zu fririeden
war zumindest was wir an Rückmeldung
bekommen haben auf auf jeden Fall die
Leute waren richtig begeistert die
Messeveranstalter war begeistert der
Veranstalter war übrigens super genau
man muss dazu sagen der Veranstalter war
super die Messe war super toll
organisiert wir hatten wirklich gar
keine Probleme alles war da was wir
gebraucht haben Wasseranschluss
Stromanschluss und das ist natürlich für
die Aussteller so wie wir es sind sehr
sehr wichtig denn man hat wirklich sehr
viel Arbeit die Messe die Aussteller
alle haben sehr viel Arbeit und dann ist
es wirklich toll wenn alle Hand in Hand
arbeiten und es wurde natürlich eine
tolle Show geliefert außer außer
außerhalb von uns gab es wirklich tolle
Stände tolle war einfach alles eine
Attraktion also nicht nur unser Stand
sondern auch wirklich ganz viele andere
Stände und das tolle war fand ich ganz
cool am Schluss kamen dann manche Messe
Messebauer zu uns von anderen Ständen
und haben sich bei uns bedankt und
gesagt schön dass ihr da warart und das
hat mich so stolz gemacht und es war
wirklich ganz toll das war keine
Konkurrenz oder sowas war einfach nur
genial alle haben sich W jedes Jahr
gerne wieder Wels wirklich ganz ganz
Daumen nach oben und ich habe von Leut
von allen Leuten mit den ich geredet
haben die waren alle begeistert wirklich
absut auch getoppt und die
Zuschauerzahlen auch noch mal höher als
letztes Jahr ja das stimmt ja beim
Aufbau ist es immer so dass unsere
starken Männer aus dem Team natürlich
immer den ganzen Stand aufbauen wir
Frauen danke wir Frauen beschäftigen uns
dann eher mit frauenarbeiten sage ich
jetzt mal so daher gesagt also ich mache
das immer ganz gerne so dass die Männer
mir schon mal den Herd anschließen den
Backofen anschließen und ich dann schon
mal vorbacken kann ganz typisch für
unsere messen seit ein paar Monaten
eigentlich immer dass ich den
Mississippi matpie vorbacke weil Murat
den immer ganz gerne verteilt das heißt
bevor die Messe beginnen stehe ich am
Backofen und back dann einfach und
währenddessen also während der Backzeit
gehe ich dann immer in den Shop rüber
und tu auch den Shop ein bisschen mit
aufbauen bis dann eben am Ende der ganze
Messestand da steht Freitag hat dann mit
der Messe angefangen das heißt die Messe
in Wells war jetzt di Tage lang was auch
wirklich ganz okay war der Freitag ist
dann immer so der warme Start der
leichte Start und Samstag Sonntag ist
natürlich dann immer extrem viel los für
uns war es eine Premiere dieses Jahr
wieder einen neuen Gast mit dabei zu
haben und zwar ist unser guter Freund
der jasin der ist Mentalist das heißt
was könnt ihr euch da drunter vorstellen
jastin hat so ein paar Tricks auf Lager
aber was er richtig toll macht ist
Hypnose jetzt denkt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich ah Hypnose das kenne ich
aus dem Fernsehen da sind dann
Schauspieler gebucht aber es ist
tatsächlich nicht so also Hypnose gibt's
wirklich und ich durfte es ja ich durfte
es selbst erfahren und habe dabei
zugeschaut und ich bin immer wieder
selbst begeistert und noch überwältigt
dass sowas funktionieren kann man geht
einfach in so ein anderen
Bewusstseinszustand und er macht nicht
nur Showhypnose der jasin macht auch
Therapie das heißt er kann z.B Ängste
wegmachen Allergien was macht er denn
noch raucherabgewöhnung Essens
Umstellung also wirklich ganz ganz viel
er kann ganz viel Menschen helfen und
bei uns auf der Messe ist er natürlich
da zum Unterhalten und es war wirklich
sehr schön manche haben gelacht manche
haben geweint ich war ich habe glaube
ich auch ein paar Mal geweint ich weiß
nicht ich finde es immer so emotional
und es war wirklich super schön und vor
allem waren die Zuschauer total
begeistert und ich denke die meisten
konnten es erstmal selbst nicht richtig
glauben bis S dann einfach selbst an der
Reihe waren und das tolle war dass es
eine Show war und die Leute haben sich
unterhalten gefühlt das heißt die waren
nicht nur da zum Einkaufen und und und
zum Shoppen und zum Essen wir haben sich
wi unterhalten geführt ich finde das ist
das coolste an einer Messe wenn du die
Leute unterhältst und die sagen wow echt
toll und und und se was anderes und das
versuchen wir den Zuschauern auchmer zu
bieten genau also wenn wir auf eine
Messe gehen dann schauen wir immer dass
die Messe an sich eben schon toll ist
wir wollen einfach nicht die
Hauptattraktion sein weil dann haben wir
auch den Mega Druck ne von morgens bis
abends unterhalten das machen wir
natürlich auch aber so hat man einfach
als Besucher immer was anderes zu sehen
es gibt den tortenwettbewerb man kann so
viel Torten bestaunen da gab's auch eine
Showbühne da gab's auch eine Modenschau
z.B da habe ich live Z geguckt und
Livestream auch gemacht dann gab's auch
die Kreativmesse im hinteren Bereich das
heißt da war dann alles nähebedarf
basselbedarf wirklich alles mögliche und
natürlich auch die anderen Stände auf
der kuchenmesse waren wirklich super
genial und das hat uns natürlich sehr
gut gefallen aber jetzt können wir mal
zeigen was jasin so gemacht hat genau
wir zeigen jetzt mal so ein paar
Ausschnitte aus jasins
Hypnoseshow und zwar passiert jetzt
folgendes schlaf schlaf schlaf tief und
fest und noch tiefer gehst du diesmal
und jetzt vertiefen wir die Hypnose mit
dem wunderbaren Applaus den du
bekommst so und zwar folgendes du die
ich jetzt berühre bekommt jetzt ein
abnormal Lachkrampf die bekommt so
Lachkrampf wie du noch nie in deinem
Leben gelacht hast und dieses Lachen
fängt jetzt schon an und es wird noch
stärker und stärker dust so extrem du
das ist
laublich und dein Lachen das ist so
abnormal wie noch nie in deinem Leben
ein Z
D und es wird noch mehr und das
Besondere ist wenn ich meine rechte Hand
hebe dann hörst du automatisch auf und
wenn ich meine linke Hand hebe fängst du
wieder an achtung wenn ich meine rechte
Hand hörst du automatisch auf und links
fängst du automatisch
an links fängst du an und wieder tief
und fest tief und fest so und du du bist
jetzt der Murat hallo mat du bist jetzt
der mat du bist der mat hallo
hallo geh du bist die S du bist jetzt
die S du bist die S hallo Hall wer bist
du hallo bist du die S und wer ist
das so ähm sag mal etwas was deine
Tochter niemals machen würde irgendwas
spinat ist spinat ist sehr gesund haben
wir Spinat hier bisschen okay pass auf
sie würde das nie essen warum nicht
we okay pass auf bei 3 öffnest du deine
Augen und du liebst es Spinat zu essen
das schmeckt dir so lecker dass es jetzt
dein Lieblingsgericht ist hallo guck mal
was wir hier haben was ist das magst du
das
schmeckt dir Schlaf ne ma auf so ess es
fertig
bevor du hast sie mit erlebt du hast sie
heute begleitet erzähl mal wie hat sich
das für dich als Zuschauer in dem Moment
angefühlt na ja es war schon komisch
weil wann man auf einmal plötzlich zu
lachen anfängt ist ja auch nicht jeden
Tag so oder dann auf die andere Sekunde
dann weint also ja es war schon komisch
kannst du dir vorstellen dass du gedacht
hast dass du die S
bist nein okay ja bist du ja nicht ne
aber dir geht richtig gut oder habe ich
das hast du
das hat sie das sie
ja hast du schon mal früher so eine
Erfahrung mitgemacht nee noch nie ich
habe auch nicht daran geglaubt okay was
an was kannst du dich noch dran
erinnern dass du gesagt hast du nimmst
zwei Personen mit
rein und an Flash ansonsten dann gar
nichts mehr kannst du dir vorstellen
dass du spinat ist na und kannst du dir
vorstellen dass du in Zukunft irgendwie
das Lust auf Spinat
bekommst GLB also ich sag dir jetzt noch
was es wird so sein dass du in Zukunft
sehr gerne Spinat essen wirst denn ich
habe jetzt etwas gemacht und ich
aktiviere das jetzt und du wirst gerne
Spinat essen es wird sich jetzt für dich
ein bisschen eigenartig anfühlen aber
ich werde jetzt noch kurz was mit dir
machen und dann isst du ganz viel Spinat
weil du es gerne ist weil das ist
nährreich ja da sind ja nur Vitamine
drin möchtest du okay Achtung Schlaf
tief und fest und spinat gehört ab heute
zu einem deiner Lieblingsgerichte spinat
ist für dich sehr wertvoll es ist etwas
besonderes und du wirst ab heute gerne
Spinat essen du liebst es Spinat zu
essen deine Mutter wird wahrscheinlich
verwundert sein dass du ab heute so
gerne spinat ist und du wirst sehen
Spinat du liebst Spinat spinat ist so
einer deiner Lieblings Gerichte bei drei
bist du wieder hellwach so dass die
Hypnose nur bei mir in dem Moment gerade
funktioniert wenn jemand so schnipst
oder so dann passiert das nicht aber es
funktioniert bei mir jetzt ansonsten
wenn du jetzt heute den Tag erlebst wird
es nicht passieren bei dre öffnest du
deine Augen bist wieder im hier und im
Jetzt und spinat gehört zu einem deiner
Lieblingsspeisen ein Z und D so magst du
Spinat ja magst du ST du das gerne ja
sehr schön kannst morgen Spinat machen
aber natürlich gab's nicht und die
Hypnoseshow denn hauptsächlich habe ich
in der Küche gekocht und gebacken und
ich glaube es war auch immer ziemlich
lecker und ja was habe ich gemacht Morat
es gab wieder Smoothies die gehen eben
super schnell sind super lecker und wir
brauchen natürlich die Vitamine für den
ganzen Tag es gab viel gebackenes ich
habe herzhaftes gemacht super hab Gemach
mit Käse habe ich gemacht Hörnchen habe
ich gemacht mit nouurt hab die
nouerteile hast du gemacht die nou war
ganz toll was man ich auchgemacht haben
und so ein quarkölteig und habe ich dann
nucker rein und Bananen das war super
lecker und und dann haben wir über glaub
über 1000 Silikonform
verschenkt Silikonform dann 1000
Päckchen Bonbons genau bonb 3000
Packungen dekoblumen haben wir
verschenkt von dekobach genau dann gab's
noch Käse haben wir verlost Handtücher
obbladen haben wir ST wir haben 5 K
nouurt verschenkt also es war wirklich
super vor allem rufen wir natürlich die
Sponsoren einfach an und sagen Mensch
wir gehen auf Messe könnt ihr uns
vielleicht was liefern und das ist
natürlich extrem toll denn dann bekommen
die Zuschauer die einfach stundenlang da
auch stehen und warten und uns sehen
etwas kostenloses mit was heißt etwas
also schon vi ich GLB es geh keiner leer
aus es ich glaube auch dass keiner von
der Messe runter ist ohne was bekommen
zu haben wir machen das halt so viel wie
wir halt haben wie bekommen und
verteilen das immer gerne an die Leute
genau und bei uns geht's natürlich auch
Essen und Trinken immer kostenlos das
heißt auch wenn ihr auf der Messe
unterwegs seid dann kommt immer bei uns
vorbei bei uns verdurstet und verhungert
keiner ja ja was immer ganz schön war
ich habe den Abschluss meiner Koch und
backshow immer mitm jahsin zusammen
gemacht und es war immer ja ich muss
sagen eine ziemlich emotionale
Abschiedsrunde weil es natürlich auch
sehr schön ist ich lernne da immer euch
kennen und viele Geschichten auch und
ich habe dann immer so in die Runde
gefragt was war denn dein schönstes oder
emotionalstes Erlebnis mit Sally mit
meinen Videos und da kam wirklich alles
zustande also da war irgendwie die
Geburt meiner Tochter und kurz vorher
habe ich Videos angeschaut oder ein
Heiratsantrag bekommen und da war ein
zellikuchen also wirklich super schön
und der jahasin hat es dann auch echt
immer schön gemacht mit der Schneeflocke
genau und mit dem vielen Schnee der dann
durch die ganze Messehalle flog super
schön und diesmal ist er in Dortmund
auch wieder dabei in Dortmund ist er
auch wieder mit dabei also nächste Woche
Samstag we aber was ich noch sagen
wollte dass nach den Kochshows natürlich
auch immer eine Autogrammstunde
stattgefunden hat freitags habe ich
wirklich noch viel Zeit gehabt für jeden
aber am Samstag und am Sonntag war
einfach so viel los da mussten wir
wirklich schnell machen damit jeder an
der Reihe war und es war wirklich
unglaublich voll also ich habe alles
unterschrieben wieder Schuhe Schürzen
Bücher da war wieder alles dabei ich
habe nur gesagt Haut unterschreibe ich
nicht da wäre ich mich dagegen aber
alles andere war okay ja in Dortmund ist
der jasin auch wieder mit dabei genauso
der Murat und natürlich auch unser
lieber Freund Mark von kochblume wieso
ist er dabei ich habe GT der kommt gar
nicht mit hat den eingeladen natürlich
geht er mit dasin ernst und es wird
wirklich super lustig also wir vier das
wird lustig aber wir wir machen aus dass
immer zwei in der Küche sind okay okay
also ja
ich und du und Mark nein
oder jeden Fall es wird lustig also wir
sind samstags und sonntagst auf der
Messe in Dortmund nächsten Samstag und
Sonntag und es wird sehr lustig wir sind
von morgens bis abends da und auch
wirklich ja die ganze Zeit über
eigentlich wir nehmen uns immer nur kurz
Pause zum ausruhen und dann sind wir
sofort wieder für Euch da genau was
möchte noch sagen auf der Messe gab es
einen richtig tollen tortenwettbewerb
und ich kann wieder nur meinen Respekt
aussprechen
und ja also die Torten waren dieses Jahr
auch wieder der Hammer es sind wirklich
Torten mit dabei ja klar die kann man
nicht essen weil es einfach schon so
Kunstwerke sind da wird wochenlang dran
modelliert und dekoriert aber man muss
wirklich sagen handwerklich sind die
alle wirklich top und ich bin ganz froh
dass ich nicht in der Jury mit dabei bin
und das nicht entscheiden muss welche
Torte nun Bronze Silber oder Gold
bekommt also wenn man jetzt gerade die
3D Torten anschaut die hirort wir
konnten gar nicht alles zeigen W alle
gezeigt hten wir jetzt an 50 Minuten
Video gewesen also für die Bilder jetzt
woll nicht drauf tut uns leid wir
konnten wir nicht alle zeigen war
wirklich alle genale Werke wirklich und
und der erste Preis war dann eine
Küchenmaschine die Waren von uns wir
haben K Maschine gestellt als erster
Preis und und waren alle Torten schön
vor allem die kinderkategorie finde ich
so schön weil wirklich auch Kinder schon
so kreativ sind da war das Thema Sommer
das heißt viele haben den Strand gemacht
mit Wasser eine sandkurk war auch mit
dabei und auch alle anderen Torten in
den Erwachsenen Kategorien war natürlich
der
[Musik]
Hammer
ja und nach drei anstrengenden aber sehr
sehr schönen Messetagen mussten wir dann
schon am dritten Tag abends Abbauen der
Abbau muss ich sagen geht Gott sei Dank
ein bisschen schneller als der Aufbau
weil der Abbau D nur 6 Stunden ja weil
einfach alle mit dabei sind und alle
nach Hause wollen und dann bauen wir
schnell zusammen und ich wäre ja nicht
die si wenn ich nicht beim Abbau auch
fürs leibliche wohl meines Teams sorgen
würde das heißt das ist irgendwie schon
zur Tradition geworden dass ich dann
nach der Messe wenn alle Besucher weg
sind einfach noch koche und backe dieses
Mal gab es wieder Pizza war ziemlich
lecker vor allem ist es eine tolle
Resteverwertung denn wir haben natürlich
auch ein bisschen Lebensmittelreste
immer da der Rest wird mir nach Hause
genommen und ja es ist dann immer
ziemlich lustig also dann rufe ich immer
durchs Mikrofon Pizza ist fertig und
dann kommen alle und Essen Pizza ja es
ist so richtig freundschaftlich ist so
eine richtige Tour als schulankheim
gehen wird also am liebsten hätte ich so
ein großen Bus wo ir alle 20 reinpassen
und ich wä der Busfahrer ja das W cool
das W wä echt cool der frank hat sich
die Finger gebrochen oh der arme ja der
hat sich den Finger gebrochen der die
ganze Zeit so ein Verband drum gehabt
und den hatte ich immer fast im Auge
wenn er mir das Mikrofon so dran gemacht
hat ich würde sagen ich glaube das war
genug Einblick in die Messe wir freuen
uns schon aufs nächste Wochenende auf
Dortmund am 27 und 28 Mai in der
Westfalenhalle da sind wir von morgens
Uhr bis abends 18 Uhr für Euch da an
beiden Tagen und ja bringt einfach
Hunger mit und Durst mit und Gen das ist
die Cake übrigens die Cake and bake
genau das ist die Cake and bake Messe
und da freue ich mich schon richtig
drauf also letztes Jahr war sie schon
genial und dieses Jahr wird sie bestimmt
auch gen genau und D haben wir eine
eigene Messehalle wie gesagt Ding ist
jas ist dabei der Shop ist dabei alle
mit dabei der Mark ist mit dabei genau
wir bringen viel Spaß mit zuk Morat ist
dabei bitte bring kein zuk hab
haben so vielkommen und bitte keine
Geschenke mit GKE bitte es haben ganz
ganz viele Leute ganz viele Sachen
gebrachtau aber ich glaube jetzt haben
wir genug gesagt die Zuschauer die jetzt
noch dabei sind möchten natürlich wissen
wer hat denn jetzt einen Scout
Schulranzen gewonnen oder eine selbst
gebastelte Sally schultöte jetzt hole
ich mal kurz die Preise und nenn dann
die Gewinner wir haben die Gewinner
einfach per Zufall ermittelt und hatten
ja gesagt vier Gewinner sind aus dem
Schul schultorte Video und vier Gewinner
sind aus dem Schultüte Video den blauen
Schulranzen goal hat eine Zuschauerin
auf Instagram gewonnen und zwar
mandarine fr Dir gehört dieser
Schulranzen den pretty Rose Schulranzen
hat eine Zuschauerin auf Youtube
gewonnen und zwar Anne achense
herzlichen Glückwunsch den
delfinschulranzen hat eine Zuschauerin
von Youtube gewonnen und zwar Leonie
reboloso
castuera war nicht vor ich wollte mir
den Namen merken aber es ging nicht wo
war das bei Youtube oder YouTube und
hier haben wir eine Facebook Gewinnerin
vom seek schulransen und zwar Steffi vom
K genau seek Steffi vom K seek Steffi
von K jetzt kommen wir zum schultütenv
da gab es ja auch vier Gewinne und zwar
zwei Schulranzen und zwei selbstgemachte
Schultüten den blauen Formel 1
Schulranzen hat eine Youtube Zuschauerin
gewonnen und zwar heißt sie viine und
den Mandala hat gewonnen Nikolova
Katharina von
Facebook die mädchenschultüte hat auf
Youtube die Mary Lou gewonnen und da
jetzt noch wichtig zu wissen was hier
drauf geschrieben werden soll also
welcher Mädchenname falls ich den Name
nicht bekomme oder du es nicht möchtest
kannst du auch einfach selbst den Namen
drauf schreiben und das ist eine
selbstgemachte Schultüte selbstgemachte
Schultüte von
S und die blaue Schultüte mit dem
Fußballmotiv hat von Facebook Angelica
Fricke gewonnen und auch hier gilt hier
oben kommt noch der Name drauf entweder
kann ich das machen brauche aber dann
den Namen des Jungen oder du machst es
einfach selber und dann haben wir noch
einen Sonderpreis und
zwar verlose ich noch ein Buch und zwar
bekommt die Berry S von YouTube und ja
da hat mich einfach Ihre Nachricht se
berührt und deswegen schicke ich dir und
deinem Kind gerne dieses Kinderbuch
herzlichen Glückwunsch an alle Gewinner
wichtig ist jetzt dass ihr euch
innerhalb von einer Woche also von 7ben
Tagen meldet also bis zum nächsten
Samstag da sind wir auf Messe aber das
ist egal bis dahin wir schauen abends
natürlich immer in die E-Mails rein bis
zum Samstag bitte melden unter folgender
E-Mailadresse mit dem vollständigen
Namen am besten noch den Namen des
Kindes das den Schulranzen oder die
Schultüte gewonnen hat da kann ich
nämlich noch eine persönliche Karte dazu
schreiben und falls ihr euch nicht
melden solltet innerhalb von einer Woche
werde ich einfach andere Zuschauer per
Los ermitteln und die dann eben auch
noch genau seid uns da nicht böse wir
haben wirklich eine Woche habau euch
Zeit zu melden ja und wenn ihr euch
gemeldet habt schicken wirs sofort raus
genau und ja herzlichen Glückwunsch an
alle Gewinner vielen Dank fürs Mitmachen
und ich find es krass weil das sind ja
schon viele Preise also ich glaub
alleine die Schulranzen haben Wert von
1500 € ja also das sind ja immer
vierteilige Sets das heißt ihr braucht
da wirklich gar nichts anderes mehr fürs
Kind da ist eine große Sporttasche mit
dabei neben dem Schulranzen dann ein
voll ausgestattetes Mäppchen und
natürlich auch so ein Schlampermäppchen
für Kleber und Schere also wirklich ganz
großzügige Preise von
und die zwei Schultüten die werden auch
noch ein bisschen befüllt von mat und
mir und dann schicken wir die auch auf
den Weg also vielen Dank fürs
Einschalten ich freue mich auf alle
unsere Besucher auf der Messe in
Dortmund auf der cake and bake nächste
Woche Samstag nächste Woche Samstag und
sone safe Date ich kann wirklich ehesag
kaum erwarten und ja jetzt packen wir
hier die schulranfen weg und dann haben
wir wieder ein bisschen Platz in unserem
Wohnzimmer bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
tschüss und danke noch mal an alle
Österreicher ja vielen Dank es war so
schön bei Euch tschüss am liebsten wä
ich jetzt selbst wieder ein Kind guck
mal ich habe immer alles verloren weißt
du das du hattest doch nichts ich hatte
ja ich hatte ja nichts nee ich hatte
nein andere hab nichts aber ich hatte
gar nichts
[Musik]
ja
you I don't remember
your that I can't
[Musik]
recnia soon you gone and already
done
cfornia
there BL for
me
to
[Musik]
cfornia ch but you gone and
alreadyia
[Musik]
se ich akmüde aus nein oder
nein
[Musik]
hallo hört mich jemand schon jemand da
also ich bin jetzt auf der Messe in
Welz ich warte noch ein bisschen paar
Leute kommen
oh Gott sind die ersten Zuschauer schon
da okay die ersten sieben sind schon da
also guck mal ich bin jetzt auf der
Messe in Welz auf der tortenmesse und
ich Filme euch jetzt noch mal ein
bisschen ist gerade noch an
Autogrammstunde es geht langsam Ende zu
große Hype der ist wir ich schon weg es
war wirklich gigantisch oh Gott ich habe
mich voll geschmt mit so einer Creme auf
jeden Fall mal ich wde euch mal g
bisschen was zeigen ich würde euch mal
jetzt ich gehe später noch zu Sally aber
ich zeige mal ein paar Torten die
ausgestellt wurden guck mal das sind
alles Torten okay die kannst nicht essen
aber sehen echt toll aus guck mal hier
das ist auch eine
Torte
und ich würde euch einfach mal zeigen
was es alles gibt an Torten wir haben
echt alles gefilmt das ist echt der
Wahnsinn ist auch eine
Torte mal hier
z.B mal ist auch eine
[Musik]
Torte also wirklich ganz ganz ganz ganz
ganz tolle Sachen hier die Hexe auch
richtig
toll motivten kann man nicht essen aber
die sehen echt toll aus mal noch weiter
und zwar das sind mal die kindertoppen
das machen Kinder ich glaube sind B bis
8 oder 10 Jahre alt wo steht zgar dran
guck mal hier sie hat zgar ein Gold
bekommen das das haben wirklich Kinder
gemacht ich würde euch gerne mal alle
zeigen und noch schöner aber wir haben
leider die Zeit nicht ich kann nicht so
lange live machen weil ich kein Akku
habe und meine Stimme versagt jetzt
langsam wirklich es waren alles Kids die
das gemacht haben mal richtig süß oder
ach Gott ist das
süß so
Urlaub Bauernhof richtig schön guck mal
hier seht ihr auch die Kids die das
machen mal ganz ganz großes Talent ach
Gott si das süß aus h dass meine Tochter
das auch mal macht richtig
schön mal hier 10 Jahre alt hier ist
Christina 10 Jahre alt ma ganz toll
wirklich ganz toll jetzt gehen wir noch
mal ganz kurz in in die in die Fantasy
Kategorie das möchte ich auch noch kurz
zeigen guck mal hier
z.B ich glaube das ist in Österreich ist
das kommen aus Österreich was ist
das schön das B okay stimmt bei uns in
Deutschland auch ich sorry ich habe
gedacht österreichisches das ist der
schön und das
Biest muss lachen hier wahrscheinlich
von von der unendlichen Geschichte
genau hier guck mal das ist mal cool das
ist mal eine Nähmaschine das ist eine
Torte kein Spaß ganz toll od guck mal
hier das ist mal so eine Bron Statue
echt eine Torte richtig toll gemacht
boah guck mal das sieht toll aus oder
ich will nicht wissen wie lange die
Leute dafür gebraucht haben auch für
diese Torte hier ach Gott wenn wenn das
jetzt keine Torte wä ich Willich ein
Bein abreißen ach Gott ist das süß guck
mal an die Katze an ach Gott guck mal
der Joker ist die Maus ach Gott ist das
cool genau guck mal hier das ist auch
cool aber guck mal da hat vielleicht
jemand was rumgefummelt oder nee es war
ein Transportschaden wahrscheinlich ach
guck mal wie schön oh je mal auch Gold
bekommen okay ich geh jetzt zu einer zu
einer Kategorie gehe ich noch und zwar
was ich auch ganz toll fand sind die
kochzeitstorten ach Gott ich muss euch
alles zeigen irgendwie guckt euch mal
das an das ist auch eine Torte das hat
die Birgit und hat dafür Silber bekommen
richtig toll gemacht hier noch
Torte mal die Torte an ganz toll ihr
müsst halt verstehen dass man diese
Torten nicht essen kann es geht wirklich
nur die
Dekoration mal das ist auch ganz toll
ganz schöne Torten oder echt toll
wunderbar ein Traum so ich habe nur noch
20% Akku ich muss EU noch so viel zeigen
ich kann noch noch schnell zu den
hochzeitstocken Achtung ein Moment ich
ich spring schnell rüber
übrigens das ist die schlangeke von der
selli seit heute morgen ganz kurz ganz
kurz
hier ich zeig noch kurz die
Sally das ist die Schlange die geht hier
rum die geht hier rum das ist ewig und
der ganze Tag schon richtig cool ich ma
gerade Instagram live genau mal
schwanger grüßt euch ich ma gerade inst
mach die Kamera aus mach die Kamera aus
die Kamera nein warte kurz die ganze
also wir sind
hier ma ger Facebook live echt Co und
wie hat die toenmäig gefallen sehr schön
wirklich also war so viele liebe
Menschen da jetzt habe ich gerade den
Abschluss in der Küche gemacht war
bisschen emotional ich bin ja ein
bisschen nah am Wasser gebaut aber war
einfach die Anstrengung der letzten Tage
und da waren so viele nette Menschen da
und GU meine und haben auch hat sie hat
die hat ein Baby dabei übrigens ganz
cool und sie hat die Nähmaschine gemacht
die singernägelmaschine gell
genau und und der Freund der musste mit
der wurde gezwungen g ist zum Schleppen
zu fragen genau ich habe meinen Freund
übrigens gesagt ich gehe nicht auf den
kuchenmesse son h sie mich beleidigt ich
habe gesagt ich gehe in den Wald jagen
ohne ohne
Waffen weiter
wiken cool voll süß die Leute
hallo guck mal sie kommt übrigens aus
dem Schwabenländle sie hat das
Schwabenländle verlassen sie ist
Schauspielerin in Salzburg und hat
studiert und sie hat Deutschland und das
schwabenländ verlassen wegen der Liebe
so ist er ist Schuld genau okay wie
hat's euch gefallen auf der Messe war
voll genial es war echt der Hammer und
die hat sich Zeit genommen und es war
einfach tolles Erlebnis hier mal gewesen
zu sein hat sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt
und die Sachen zum Essen waren super
danke schön danke dir
auchck mal das ist dann Shop das ist der
Buddy Buddy wink mal Facebook live okay
ist Shop hier s die Leute oh sorry hey K
grüß ist die Veranstalter in der Messe
ich ma kein Facebook live und es war
richtig erfolgreich aber richtig cool
echt super organisiert danke schön danke
dass ihr da super ganz hi ach so ich
machz Facebook live okay ich komme
gleich zu euch
so und wie gesagt das ist ein Shop hier
ist alles hier kann man alles holen und
allem drum und dran Sachen hier sind
Sachen ausgestellt dass die Zuschauer
mal sehen können was ist was ist
günstige Ware was ist billige Ware was
ist gute Ware dann haben wir hier z.B
auch so für die Leute mal hingestellt
was was das Besondere an an sallyi ist
ihr seht mal das ist als Deutschland
hergestellt ist einhal der
Umweltstandards wir zeigen hier auch z.B
äh was die Unterschiede zwischen
Qualität und nicht Qualität
ist genau das zeigenigen zuschau hier
ist
z.B die H erklärt jetzt auch was was gut
ist was schlecht ist genau wen mein Teig
einfach immer ein bisschen dicker ist
also ich habe nur noch 10% Akku ich
wollte aber un noch zu hochzeitstotten
ich wollte noch viel mehr zeigen also es
ist richtig wahnsinnig und es wir
eigentlich schon am Ende der Messe und
es ist immer noch viel los echt tollegan
muss ich wirklich sagen es war richtig
genial die Leute haben viel Platz hier
hab eine Bühne hier werden auch viele
Sachen
gezeigt ich krieg kaum noch Luft ich
krieg kaum noch Luft also es ist der
Wahnsinn es ist wirklich toll gemacht
ganz ganz großes Kompliment an die
Österreicher ihr hab es ganz toll
gemacht ich habe noch hochzeitstopen ich
euch unbedingt zeigen wollte guck mal
das ist wirklich Kunst das ist wirklich
toll gemacht ganz toll und ich zeige
meine lieblingshochzeit immer sind alle
toll wirklich alle toppen sind toll aber
ich habe hier so eine kleine
Lieblingstorte gefunden das ist so
Pärchen hat auch Gold bekommen das war
die Nadin Stein hat es bekommen und zwar
ganz ganz toll gemacht diese Torte ist
eine
Hochzeitstorte in Dortmund haben wir
auch in unseren eigenen Stand Lauf kein
Akku mehr ich habe echt kein Akku mehr
es tut mir so leid ihr wisst Murat Leben
immer am Limit ach guck mal da hinten
das muss ich auch noch zeigen guck mal
hier und zwar ist es konditorlehrling
und jungkonditoren bis 25 vier Jahres
Zeiten guck mal auch ganz toll gemacht
das sind jetzt von den
Profis ganz tolle Torten aber ihr seht
man muss nicht unbedingt ein Profi sein
und ganz tolle Torten zu machen es gibt
auch wirklich Leute die sind keine
Profis sind keine Konditoren und die
machen das ganz cool dekoratives Element
ist auch
hier sind die Themenvorgaben 100% essbar
nur essbare innere Stützen erlaubt also
das kann man alles essen das ist cool
jetzt das gefällt mir ach guck mal der
Uhu sieht aus wie mein Schwiegervater
okay weiter weiter beev die S genau hier
und was ich noch unbedingt zeigen wollte
ganz toll ich finde das mit den Schürzen
ganz toll das ist auch so eine
modeakademie und die haben die Schürzen
gemacht und die Schürzen sind echt cool
guck mal das ist Maline Schürze klar die
bekomt jetzt nicht für 20 € diese
Schürzen und aber richtig toll
gemacht cool guck mal die würde ich auch
gern für die Sally holen die mir
gefallen das Besondere an dieser Schürze
ist dass es Kork ist es ist wirklich
Kork und das ist dann österreichisch
bayerisch find ich richtig toll das ist
auch eine richtig tolle Schürze das auch
auch so jetzt gehen noch weiter mir
bleibt nicht mehr viel
Zeit ist das in Wien nein das ist in
Wels das ist in Österreich und bald auch
in Dortmund hier s bei kitchen also ist
auch uns am Stand hier gibt Angebote und
allem dran hier ist hier ist der Benny
so ist Benny hi
Ben und ihr wollt kitchn Maschine okay
pass auf wenn ihr im Benny die Hälfte
nur glaubt was er sagt seid immer noch
gut angelogen na ja ich habe Hal vom
Besten gelernt danke schön danke schön
der jasin hier jas Instagram live hallo
wir sind live genau der jas ist
Mentalist ihr seht es noch in den Videos
nachher sch mal her wer möchte noch von
dem Aufstrich guck mal hier haben wir
auch richtig ins Zeug der ist
riesig schon
in möch noch ein bisschen aufstr haben
wir n mehr da
powerb komm mal her komm her ich muss
was sagen ja Leute der der hat hier auf
der Messe schaut mal die Küche hier an
gib mal das
Ding du hast nicht meh vi zeig noch sch
mal was kaputt gemacht hat
Katastrophe dankeön W unbedingt hier auf
[Musik]
der
bildte danke schön vielen Dank danke da
warentlich glob extakasse auf wenn
kommen sind wenn sie mich kommen
natürlich natürlich ext morgens immer
dann
tschüs mal das ist der daniel Daniel
hallo Daniel sag mal hallo hallo Daniel
beraten ja was geht um die gour die ne g
genau okay ganz gut dann ist hab noch
andere
Stände Grüße an ma ich erst das Bett ach
Gott guck mal ich hab gestern Bett
kaputt gemacht von der S ich weiß jetzt
darf ich geh mal kurz hinten rein dass
mal hinten Kulissen sieht was ich ist
bisschen jetzt eine Sauerei seid mir
nicht böse mal wir gehen jetzt hinten
rein so so sieht bei uns aus im
Lager klar Biss Unordnung was m machen
jetzt hab jetzt hat so ein fettb
bekommen und ich habe Bett kaputt
gemacht gestern ja jetzt hat so ein
Sitzsack bekommen jetzt gehenit hinten
rum hier ist ein bisschen Lager ist ein
bisschen chaotisch aber das ist auf
Messen so so jetzt gehen wir hinten rein
und dann gehen wir raus und
hier so auf jeden Fall we die jetzt auch
nichtr da ist m am Schluss hallo Tom
genau ein cooles T-Shirt an das gefällt
mir
super auf jeden Fall guck mal da ist
immer noch die Schlange von der Sally
und wir sind wirklich am Ende wenn ich
noch ein bisschen Akku hätte würde ich
noch weiter mit euch eine kleine Tour
machenens also wirklich das ist
Markus grüß Dich hallo B der Markus das
ist ein ber der ist auch von Kenwood
richtig cool was man auch sagen
muss richtig cool oder komisch dass die
ein Bild von mir da
ist mit mir ein Foto ja komm machen mal
eins ja Maus komm her aber ich kenwoher
kann sein von Wien ach cool komm mach
mal ein
Foto
gehtery danke schön vielen Dank tschüss
natürlich ma auch ein Foto mit mir ja
die Fotos mit mir sind viel wertvoller
weil so selten sind und die mit S sind
unscharf danke schön s sind unscharf
geworden vielen Dank kannst du no mal
eins machen wir machen jetzt nicht mehr
zu es geht noch voll
durch ja noch mal wir zwei auch noch ja
cool komm
her unser Kleiner ist s s verrückt dan
zeig nicht sein Gesicht a Gott ist das
süß aber die S hat gestern vom Armend
das ist so cool e der kleine BAK ach
Gott seind die Türken ja wieind nicht
aus
wie Wahnsinn
cool ja die sagen nur noch zu mir ich
hab ich dies Woch 3 Kil ges bekmen
mindestens mindestens dann hast du mal
Vorrat holt euch noch was zu trinken
alles kostenlos okay wir sehen uns g
tschüss also ganz ganz liebe Leute
wirklich das ist ech wahnsinn was wie
lieb diese Menschen hier sind und wie
aufrichtig sie sind wie liegbt i mir und
was ich alles machen
Wahnsinn Michelle ich würde mir eine
kenw holen dann gehst mal bei S Shop da
kannst du Ken holen von einem
Familienbetrieb von Fachhändler wir
wollen machen noch komm komm wir machen
auch gleichzeitig noch Instagram
live danke schön vielen Dank auch noch
komm her wenn das meine Mama sieht die
fliegt
aus danke schön vielen
Dank nur wir zwei mal noch ein ja
natürlich guck mal
hier
okay
geht's ja danke danke wir sehen uns
nächstes jah wieder in Wels okay
tschüss auch noch
Mädels wenn Mama aus so
[Musik]
Vich snat
aufgesetzt danke
schön noch gar nur Hel hier Ding ich ma
gerade Instagram live Facebook live okay
wir sehen uns gleich noch
mal Danke Schön wir sehen uns gleich
noch
mal also richtig cool Wahnsinn oder ja
läuft bei mir ir heute ja natürlich komm
Foto achtung ich mach gleich dein Freund
ist auf Facebook
Live Super dan liebe Grüße in schwabel
liebe Grüße in schwabelend guck mal
siehst du das alles hier schauen gerade
570 Menschen zu cool so läuft bei dir
okay ja ist Wahnsinn tschüss macht's gut
also also ich habe jetzt so ein bisschen
was gezeigt jetzt ist der Akku wirklich
gleich leer habe mich gefreut und vielen
vielen Dank an die Österreicher an die
ganzen Leute die uns besucht haben hier
auf der Messe die sally ist gerade in
der Autogrammstunde noch al wirklich
nichts mehr da aber die Schlange von der
S hört nicht auf das ist Wirich der
ganze Tag schon ganz ganz
toll ja okay hi hi wollen ein Foto
machen toal
danke schön K ganz großen Gefallen tun
könnt bei Facebook auf die kuchenmesse
gehen und es dann reinschreiben hab
wirkich
verdient ich bin e wichtiger als die ja
natlich
alles
danke schön Mel vielen Dank danke dass
sie da
wareno Bild machen
zusammen alle drei
zusammen
schön weit
vo okay pass
auf so
[Musik]
warte tschüss macht's gut vielen Dank
jasin danke schön jasin war schön alles
okay und wie war's für euch hat Spaß
gemacht cool voll cool ehrlich ja und du
warst schon mal bei uns in in in
Deutschland dabei gell in Wien warst du
dabei okay und kommt der nächstes Jahr
wieder nächstes Jahr wieder vielen
vielen Dank I war echt klasse gell danke
schön darf ich ja natürlich
L
komm her danke schön okay
tschüss okay auf jeden Fall ich hör
jetzt auf vielen vielen Dank macht's gut
Frankie willst auch noch was sagen du
hast jetzt das abschlusswort Ciao
macht's gut okay das war gut
tschüss oh oh es ging nicht Frank guck
mal die Schlange ist immer noch da